salut casimir
ville-campagne mon facteur préféré
regarder je sois en train de me préparer
cet îlot de yaourt aux cornichons c'est
mon dessert pour demain vous en prendrez
bien un peu non non non je vais vraiment
pas fin aujourd'hui non j'ai une lettre
pour toi kazemi on ne me fait pas tarder
à donner vite à hasnon une seconde parce
que l'expéditeur a oublié de mettre un
timbre dessus alors si tu veux la voir
il faut payer le double bon ben alors
gardez là je n'ai plus un sou en ce cas
je vais le renvoyer à l'expéditeur
attendait une question simple curiosité
qui est cet expéditeur discret attend à
monsieur albert travelling albert ravine
aurait coûté alors je vous en prie
facteurs au diable l'avarice payer pour
moi je suis tellement curieux de savoir
ce que ça ils sont mus titille le
travelling 20 écoute d'accord casimir
jeu je vais payer pour toi mais à titre
personnel pour la ccct mille campagne
qui va donner deux francs aux facteurs
merci monsieur quand on tue c'est
heureusement que tous mes clients
n'envoie pas des lettres nous on a
franchi si je payais pour tout le monde
mais alors là je finirai clochard mais
il me si vous êtes mon facteur préféré
c'est parce que je sais que lorsque je
quand je vous demande un service qu'on
me rende et maintenant je peux le faire
c'est très volontiers que cette
voix si voix la
casimir tiens je je parie ma casquette
contre eux contre un dépôt de fleurs que
monsieur travelling veut encore temps
mené à travers le monde dans une cage à
l'eau alors là on n'y est pas du tout
facteur votre casquette avons alors j'ai
perdu tient la voile appartenait avec
c'est à moi de vous rendre un petit
service à l'égard tu veux dire un fier
service quand je n'ai pas ma casquette
jean marc ulmann ah bon voilà ce qui se
passe monsieur travelling d'avoir une
indication pour aller aux grands music
hall denis voisine et je peux emmener
françois et julie c'est formidable ça
casimiro tu penses c'est le plus grand
musée du monde mais il faut que tu
prévois une solide mise en scène allez
au revoir bonne chance à bientôt casimir
gecko âge
ne s'enlisent mise en scène
je ne sais déjà parce que c'est qu'une
mise en scène alors une solide mise en
scène
je vais demander à judy
allons julie
moi c'est quasi mira ac poids cadets
mire comment tu vas casier
ses casinos bien dit merci j'avais
contrer dans l'écouteur il va nous
manquer quelque chose voilà je suis prêt
oui oui oui oui
dynamique nous sommes d'accord nous
ferons le maximum pour lui nous sommes
d'accord casimir et tout à l'heure le
solide mise en scène pour passer ce soir
au music hall et 20 minutes rencontre
casimir va chanter devant des centaines
de personnes il nous emmène ses 30 il
faut absolument que ce soit un énorme
succès dit julie sors de ton kiosques et
mettons nous au travail alors voyons
imaginons que la scène du music hall est
ici comme ça et que le public est ici
devant nous il faudrait d'abord le
présenter ainsi sa soeur ça se présente
toujours un artiste qui l'a chanté non
qu'on descend comme ça
et maintenant pour la toute première
fois devant vous
quasi
non c'est pas original c'est c'est pas
bon salon
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait bien trouver de
quoi je crois que j'ai trouvé
et maintenant celui que vous attendiez
tous cas vie mais
[Musique]
je vous présente celui qu'on ne présente
pas casser
encore
celui qui
représente quand même non
voici
[Applaudissements]
ses formidables sa c5 c'est directement
sapmer a beaucoup je crois que ça
apportera beaucoup à sa mise en scène
grâce à nous il va avoir un trio mission
ensuite on fera baker
casimir commencera à chanter sa chanson
avec une chanson beaucoup d'imagination
derrière on fera
alors si c'est grâce à nous ils en faire
une valeur il a beaucoup de chance de
nos avoirs suite au décès de très jolies
que nixon pour le métro vers l'est oui à
mesure vitesse
regardez mon costume de scène les
enfants qu'en pensez vous
les jolis seins j'espère que julie ne va
pas tarder en fait vous savez ce que
c'est qu'un music hall oui
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est un endroit à
l'établissement public dans lequel il un
orchestre qui accompagnent des chanteurs
et des chanteuses et aussi d'autres
numéros vous connaissez des
exactement il vous connaissez d'autres
endroits on donne des spectacles
au cinéma c'est plus le cinéma le
théâtre l'opéra
l'opéra piscine c'est ce que cet opéra
khama qui danse oui mais surtout on
chante et ne viendra c'est un poème
écrit un poème dramatique qui est chanté
aussi l'opéra bouffe qui est drôle
qu'est-ce qu'il ya aussi comme endroit
où donné spectacle de guignol
vous avez tous été aux guignols oui une
petite scène de miniatures lesquels
évoluent des marionnettes
à la maternelle ne faisait ni
physiquement soit distribution des prix
vous ai dit les entend oui il ya aussi
des salles de concert
et aussi les kiosques à musique dans les
ardennes qui n'a plus beaucoup
maintenant d'ailleurs
voilà julie
[Applaudissements]
merci julie sait que les très très belle
votre costume de scène ce soir sous les
feux des projecteurs du music hall tu va
briller de mille feux 6 4 le sport
chinois casimir n'est pas encore arrivé
il va pas tarder tiens voilà enfin un
joli bond soir françois zimeray
vous êtes très chouette comme ça savez
vous que je suis vraiment flatté de
sortir avec des amis aussi élégant vous
merci casimir pour ce soir nous avons
prévu une solide mise en scène très bien
où est elle
la solide mise en scène de casimir tu
sais ce que c'est qu'une mise en scène
[Musique]
et casimir une mise en scène c'est tout
ce qui sert à mettre en relief un
artiste qui se produit sur une scène les
projecteurs le costume qu'il porte les
déplacements qu'il fait et cetera et
cetera a beau
présenter
à l'est
alors toi casimir tu entrera en scène à
ton tour tu saluera le public tu seras
pas chanson avec une chanson oui un peu
d'imagination et nous derrière vous fera
lakers et d'histoire arrêté j'aurais au
music-hall d'accord je suis faillites et
par monsieur travelling mais enfin je ne
réponds au music-hall sur la scène
j'avais dans la salle en spectateur
est alors casimir pourquoi nous avoir
demandé de travailler une solide mise en
scène pour faire plaisir aux facteurs il
voulait absolument j'en ai une mais s'il
faut une solide mise enceinte pour aller
sur scène savez vous ce qu'il faut pour
aller dans la salle dont ces peuples et
bien i o l'une sans les grandes glaces
et à l'entracte et vous allez mon offrir
chacun une en or
[Applaudissements]